Mardi Gras is the greatest free show on Earth.
But if you've never done it before,...
...there might be some things you'll wanna know before heading out.
So we've all come together, the people who have lived here forever,...
...to tell you how we do Mardi Gras.
Definitely wear comfortable shoes.
The best advice I can give is, is you make sure you find a bathroom.
I would definitely tell 'em it's a marathon, not a sprint.
We used to do alcohol, water, alcohol, water.
Pace yourself; it's a long ride.
Bring something to put your beads in.
And last piece of advice, wear clothes you don't mind getting dirty...
...and get ready to have a great time.
I'm Fleurty Girl and that wraps up another edition of GoNOLA TV...
...and we'll see you next time, darling.